[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport à
l'émission est toujours consacrée à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
c'est parti pour le sommaire crossfit la
8e édition du french so good on s'est
déroulée ce week-end au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
plus de 9000 personnes sont venus pour
l'événement tous les détails dans ce
magazine football féminin l'équipe de
france a perdu contre les états unis
vendredi dernier ne remportera pas la
coupe du monde mais les joueuses ont
réussi à gagner le coeur des français de
nombreuses inscriptions sont à prévoir à
la rentrée dans le département pourra le
point dans quelques instants
course à pied à sidy diallo ligne
montant en plus de 100 marathon
ultramarathon sur sept continents vient
de sortir un livre son nom au running
human l'ouvragé expliqué capacité
naturelle des humains à courir pieds nus
nous lui avons posée à trois questions
l'actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
on prend tout de suite la direction du
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la structure a
accueilli pendant trois jours la 8e
édition du crossfit french redonne un
rendez vous qui a réuni plus de 9000
personnes sur les trois jours de
compétition
patrick jacques de dixmude pour les
images avantage de sandrine fontaine des
sportifs ultra musclé un rythme effréné
la fièvre du cros suite à gagner le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
pendant trois jours la structure
accueilli pour la toute première fois le
crossfit french fredonne la compétition
a attiré près de 9000 personnes dans
l'enceinte
moi je suis anglais j'ai fait ce genre
de boulot dans toutes ces pays les
infrastructures ici soit exceptionnel la
flexibilité de l'équipe aussi nous
permettent de concerts on a construit un
stade à l'extérieur on a un village
partenaires sur la compétition plusieurs
catégories tête au programme des moins
de 18 ans plus de 50 ans au total 540
participants venus de 47 pays se sont
affrontés à travers une dizaine
d'épreuves qui mêlait à la fois force
endurance précision et vitesse
même ma catégorie eric saade très gros
niveau donc ouais c'est un honneur
d'être ici
c'était vraiment un événement réussi
pour moi c'est le maire événements en
europe qui existe entre autres je
pensais pas que ce soit que ce soit si
haut niveau ça nous pousse même nous les
plus petits pour devenir plus gros et
plus fort donc très très gros niveau est
très intéressant
je pensais pas avoir autant de monde ici
et c'est vraiment bien ça montre que
crossfit a beaucoup d'importance
les meilleurs ont remporté un chèque de
dix mille euros et le droit de
participer au crossfit games
l'équivalent de la coupe du monde de la
discipline
je le succès rencontré cette année les
organisateurs discutent déjà d'un
éventuel retour au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines
on continue par le tennis évinois johan
guillou licencié à voisins le bretonneux
est devenu champion de france 1re série
en tennis fauteuil ce week-end à dijon
sous 35 degrés victoire qui permet ce
sportif de rester l'un des meilleurs
français dans sa catégorie
johan guillou espère toujours pouvoir se
qualifier pour les jeux olympiques un
jour où pour tokyo ou pour paris on va
maintenant parler football l'équipe de
france féminine ne remportera pas la
coupe du monde à domicile les filles de
corinne diacre se sont inclinés 2 buts à
1 vendredi dernier face aux états unis
une défaite amère difficile à digérer
mais les françaises pourront se consoler
en se rappelant qu'elles ont créé un
engouement autour d'elle pour nous
parler de cette équipe de france nous
recevons sur ce plateau jean loup le
plat membre du comité de direction au
district des yvelines est également à
dire exacte et guillaume qui arrive
justement en direct qui est président de
l'étoile sportive de trappes
bonjour alors que vous avez été surpris
jean leplat de cet engouement autour de
cette équipe de france féminine
non pas vraiment parce que la fédération
française de football avait bien préparé
depuis des mois la venue de toutes les
équipes participant à ce championnat du
monde
la compétition était excellemment bien
préparé il y avait une promotion qui
avait été censuré par les plus hauts
cadres de la fédération dans le monde
sportif du football et donc non ça me
paraît logique d'avoir eu de si belles
affluences dans les stades notamment
pour l'équipe de france est faut bien le
dire
abdel reza qui agace ou mais qu'est ce
qu'est ce que vous en pensez cette ago
soit engouement est ce que vous avez été
surpris vous de votre côté
non moi pour je n'ai pas été surpris
c'est un honneur d'avoir cette coupe du
monde sur le territoire sur au niveau de
la france en tout cas nous ça fait
maintenant depuis quatre saisons qu'on a
une section féminine et nous on le voit
d'année en année des inscriptions
importante aujourd'hui maintenant on
comptabilise 136 sur le club et je sais
qu'avec cette coupe du monde et cette
promotion au niveau des féminines
il y aura un peu plus de filles dans les
clubs
vous êtes convaincu qu'il y aurait plus
d'inscriptions contenant du curare plus
d'inscriptions c'est une nouvelle
pratique ça se démocratise complètement
et fille vont trouver leur place comme
les garçons au sein au sein des clubs
qui sont structurés un forcément faudra
structurer mais en tout cas je sais que
la fédération française de football et
la ligue nous nous comment dire nous
nous accompagne le poussin sur depuis
quelques années sur la création de
sections féminines
elle nous accompagne vraiment en termes
de matériel en termes de formation
d'éducatrice et ça c'est un plus pour le
club
vous confirmez change lepage confirme
absolument hommage et les chiffres entre
les deux si vous voulez du nombre de
licenciées féminines en france on est
passé de 50 mille cinq cent soixante
cinq chefs précis licenciés sportive en
2011 2012 et on arrive aujourd'hui à 184
mine de 128 licenciés et ça n'est pas
fini puisque la fédération a pour
objectif dans le cadre du plan héritage
2020 d'aboutir à 200 me licencier qui me
paraît complètement possible dans les
aiguilles en à peu près 6 2% glow
licencié à fégréac alors ce qu'on peut
peut-être regretter mais on y travaille
bien sûr monsieur présent de l'estrapadé
mer le sujet c'est d'augmenter encore le
nombre de clubs qui reçoivent une
section sportive il n'y en n'a encore
que 37 sur 153 club de nouvelles qui a
une marge de progression énorme
et en terme de clubs recevant une
section sportive également qu'un de
l'isf en 6éme étudié soumah parfaitement
le nom de dire qu'il ya quand même de
beaux clubs dont trappe c'est parti mais
bien sûr il ya d'autres entités le pg
qui est un peu hors norme une pression
est libre autonome qui reçoivent des
sections féminines qui a tué une jeune
fille pour pratiquer leur sport favori
et comment faire justement pour les
aider à lancer les structures plus de
moyens oui je crois qu'ils étaient
libyens sur les moyens humains et les
moyens financiers les moyens matériels
aussi et puis je crois cela a été dit
mais il faut souligner un effort de
promotion de la formation des élus
catrice parce qu'effectivement il nous
faut encore davantage de 2,4 et
spécialisés pour les jeunes filles mais
également pour inciter
de favoriser l'arbitrage féminin et je
sais que la dtn arbitral au sein de la
fédération instructif mais également de
ce sujet trente sept clubs sur 153 ont
une section féminine est-ce que c'est
trop peu selon vous on a une marge
on a une marge bien sûr au vu du nombre
de clubs qui a dans le département
si on regarde 37 c'est trop peu
maintenant effectivement il faut savoir
est ce que les clubs sont en capacité de
les accueillir
parce que ça demande quand même une
structuration des clubs pour accueillir
les féminines vous ouvriez parce que
tous les clubs peuvent accueillir des
sections féminines
moi je dirais eu dix clubs notamment les
petits clubs c'est un peu plus compliqué
pour eux mais c'est un peu plus
compliqué pour eux c'est indépendamment
vraiment du club en tout cas le district
accompagne ça c'est sûr accompagnement
termes de formation il ya des bons de
formation gratuits pour les féminines
pour les formes et du matériel aussi qui
met à disposition au club effectivement
après c'est des problèmes de structure
d'équipement là c'est la collectivité
qui doit voir un travail étroit avec le
club
est-ce qu'il faut former des pleins de
jeunes filles ou plutôt l'élite défis de
demain qui pourront y accéder l'équipe
de france j'avais notamment l'exemple
chez vous 2 au cn le cf qui a 13 ans qui
a été surclassée est ce qu'une fille
comme celles là ont la forme pour aller
en équipe de france
pourquoi pas ça serait un bonheur pour
le club nous l'essentiel c'est
d'accueillir faut les accueillir des
clients dans de bonnes conditions
qu'elles puissent pratiquer le football
quel zen et après une gamine qui bien qu
est bien elle sera vue par par des
niveaux supérieurs et elles partiront
d'elle-même mais le travail revient à
elle nous il faut juste les accompagner
les accueillir et qu'elles puissent
pratiquer cette activité et après le
reste se fera tout seul même si les
féminines ont perdu est-ce que vous
pensez que le soufflé ne va pas retomber
sur le bleu non je ne pense pas parce
que ce point là elle est vraiment un
engouement populaire vous l'avez dit
vous-même et
je crois que maintenant les les français
ont découvert le football féminin existe
et qui avait quand même une belle équipe
de france et qu'il y avait beaucoup de
jeunes filles qui pratiquent le football
donc je crois que cela devrait durer il
n'y a pas de raisons cela cesse je crois
que c'est nécessaire
et qu'est ce qui a plu aux français
justement mais que je crois que le jeu
fait mis un terme un peu différent quand
même du jeu masculin c'est un jeu très
esthétique même des fois un peu
académique mais je veux dire il ya des
beaux échanges c'est très collectif
c'est un beau football c'est un jeu très
esthétique c'est très beau à voir jouer
vous avez été au stade notamment pour
voir l'équipe de france en jeu si elle
est effectivement à rhein parce que la
dncg variant décentralisée à rennes et
j'ai eu le bonheur la chance de voir le
match france nigéria dans le magnifique
sac de rennes et on a que la cité une
magnifique ambiance à une destinée aux
porteurs qui brandissaient le drapeau
bleu blanc rouge qui chantait qui
faisait sonner dans smartphones qui
espérait le stade halal est tombée de la
nuit avec leur smartphone non c'était
vraiment une très très belle ambiance
alors il n'y a pas que les chez les
joueuses un contrôle de plus en plus de
féminines chez les arbitres également
dans le département elles ne
représentent que 2% des femmes en noir
mais le chiffre augmente coup de
projecteur sur natacha un portrait signé
à mélanie poké celui qu'on appelle
habituellement l'homme en noir ce jour
là c'est une femme natacha 34 ans
passionné de football depuis l'âge de 9
ans une passion communiqué par son grand
père depuis 2015
l arbitre comme officiel un match chaque
dimanche c'est un échange conte avec les
joueurs qui est privilégiée sur le
terrain ça permet de s'affirmer aussi et
puis c'est une autre facette de
pratiquer le football même si on n'a pas
le même maillot on a forcément la même
passion et on essaie de partager ça avec
avec les joueurs aussi on n'est pas là
pour pour les remettre des cartes ont
systématiquement mais pour que la
rencontre se passe bien pour le match
tout à l'heure il ya une équipe qui joue
en noir une équipe qui joue en vert les
gardiens gris et orange vérification du
terrain des licences échauffement plus
d'une heure avant le match natacha et
ses arbitres assistants prépare la
rencontre
dans sa relation avec les équipes
natacha privilégie la discussion je ne
force pas mon caractère j'arbitre
naturellement j'ai un contact assez
assez facile avec avec les joueurs je
suis pour la communication sur le
terrain donc je pense qu'avec la
communication on arrive à résoudre
beaucoup de conflits donc j'ai pas de
souci de ce côté là honnêtement avec les
joueurs germick principalement que dès
que des hommes c'est assez rare que
j'arbitre sur des matchs féminins dans
le département les femmes ne sont que 7
à officier le district compte 300
arbitres des hommes et des femmes
proposées par les clubs yvelinois en
fonction de leur niveau de compétition
si vous n'avez pas le nombre minimum
d'arbitré vous avez des sanctions pour
calculer le nombre d'arbitrés fournis
par les clubs concept une arbitres
féminines
elle compte pour 2 alors là aussi on m'a
dit 'ce tout discret c'est de la
discrimination oui mais elle est
positive et j'assume 1 voilà c'est pour
inciter les clubs à nous amener des
arbitres féminines aussi le district
organise chaque année deux formations
pour devenir arbitre
elles ont lieu en octobre et en novembre
natacha delhaize de temps en temps le
sifflet pour taper elle-même dans le
ballon sur le plat une réaction par
rapport à ce sujet je crois que cela a
été dit il y a vraiment besoin de
beaucoup darby et notamment la mitre
féminine je crois que en plus on a pu
observer des arbitres féminin évidemment
au niveau international lors de la coupe
du monde- récente mais elles ont un
excellent niveau et puis je crois que
les femmes ont peut-être l'avantagé
c'est un peu plus psychologue
des fois que les arbitres masculin et je
dois dire aussi que j'ai remarqué que
les joueurs de football à la coupe du
monde ne conteste pas les décisions des
arbitres mais je crois que ça c'est
vraiment un bon point à marquer pour le
football féminin des réacs et zoom vous
êtes d'accord avec culture le plat en
tout cas tout à fait d'accord 5 c'est
une autre pratique c'est vraiment c'est
esthétique
j'ai pu participer - une rencontre
lors de cette coupe du monde japon
argentine et c'est vrai qu'il ya une
belle ambiance c'était festif sur le
stade est ainsi que le jeu était
complètement fluide et effectivement
elle ne conteste pas les décisions
d'arbitrage les liens très grande très
grande différence avec les garçons et à
savoir si je ne me trompe pas je crois
pour la saison 2010 9 2020 on aura une
première femme arbitre qui va arbitrer
en ligue 1
comme quoi voilà l'arbitrage arrive
arrive de filmer un arbitrage alors nous
allons maintenant parler de votre
deuxième fonction jean loup le plat nous
avons invité sur ce plateau car vous
êtes également commissaire de la
direction nationale du contrôle de
gestion plus connu sous le nom de dncg
ou de gendarme financier du football
français
alors ensemble nous allons parler de cet
organe créé en 1984 comment fonctionne
la dncg orner votre rôle vous savez
effectivement dit couramment que la dncg
le gendarme financier du football entend
ça partout y compris dans la prime et
soeurs et on rappelle les mesures qui
seront prises par elle mais je crois que
c'est un petit peu la thur et du verre à
moitié plein ou à moitié vide
or s'il est vrai que la dance et je peux
prendre des mesures d'ordre financier
dans administrative mais elle pratique
aussi je dirais un mode d'information de
communication à l'égard des flots mais
je crois que le kop sang révèle
satisfaire enfin moi c'est la patte que
j'ai de culte ya un an que je suis au
sein de cette dncg on au niveau
financier si je puis me permettre
katie moyen simple de mesures qui
peuvent être prises vers une mesure
d'encadrement de la masse tient à l'ucl
quand le club prenne ça c'est le plus
petit niveau ça des niveaux mais les
niveaux important c'est d'éviter le
au club d'aller dans le mur comme nous
disons couramment et de se tromper
abandonné deux doigts ne pas présenter
de mauvais comptes il ya la rétrogration
administrative en signe de la
résignation sportif qui ne mesure plus
sévère
c'est déjà arrivé et piper aussi avoir
une autorisation d'accession en division
supérieure
ça veut dire que tout est ouvert ces
politiques on peut les fait monter le
club
il prévoit aussi un refus d'accession à
l'élite supérieur c'est effectivement le
compte ne prennent part donc 30 juin des
comptes satisfaisants nous pouvons
refuser l'accession et nous l'avons déjà
fait
alors après il ya d'autres mesures genre
retraite points et je suis les
compétitions des amendes ans que les
documents seront pas représentés à bonne
date
il ya toute une batterie que je dirais
de mesures que nous pouvons prendre à
l'égard des crottes
mais alors si je puis me permettre
concernant les mesures lino plus
positive on a réussi pour habitude de
donner des conseils des informations au
club on peut très bien leur donner des
passes qu'on peut dire que vous êtes en
la prévention oui aussi oui oui passion
les aidons les aides et croyez moi les
clubs lorsqu'ils reviennent nous voir
une deux trois quatre saisons plus tard
vous nous avez dit vous nous avez
conseillé t ou telle chose on l'a fait
et on est bien content d'avoir fait donc
lors d'années venant par exemple une
information juridique sur les textes au
milieu a passionnément il ya des clubs
qui défendent connaître dans les flaques
chevaux d'écran meilleur ou financiers
comptables on est dans un fort ont pour
leur recommander aussi un certain nombre
de points
on peut les informer en matière sociale
ce régime des franchises et les basses
en fait taire qui permettent de payer
les cotisations sociales à un taux moins
on leur donne une information sur la
bonne utilisation des frais de
déplacement on peut leur comique et
décontracté le mécénat et sponsoring
passieu rappelez-vous et les clubs s'ils
ne vivent pas uniquement que d'eau
fraîche un lieu de sponsoring de mécénat
deux subventions publiques qu'ils n'ont
pas ça ne peuvent pas vivre ça ferait
bien clair donc on les conseille dans
tous ces domaines là je pense que les
clubs se retrouvent satisfait l'arrivée
donc voyez c'est donnant-donnant vient
de communiquer avait justement va
demander l'avis vous avez des raisins
guessoum
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous la
dncg est-ce que c'est contraignant la
voie du non pas du tout pas du tout moi
moi je lui dis nous on n'est pas non on
est pas dans ce cadre la dcng on est en
régionale 3 on va monter en régionale 2
mais en tout cas le club et ça c'est
très important c'est le point financier
très important d'un club c'est là qu'on
voit que c'est un club bien structuré et
s'il est en bonne santé
la bonne santé d'un club c'est les
financent aussi on peut avoir une
structure un niveau de pratique mais
derrière il ya des frais il ya des des
dépenses est derrière et en tout cas
nous nous on est on est bien accompagné
vous avez raison il faut être accompagné
on est accompagné parce qu'on valide nos
comptes un expert-comptable sac et
validé tous les ans et effectivement il
ya des recommandations il ya des
rectifications à faire sur du certains
domaines sur la franchise urssaf sur la
masse salariale on a des salariés
campent au pouvoir bénéficier des
cotisations comment pouvoir d'effrayer
nos éducateurs faut savoir on a des
éducateurs aujourd'hui qu'ils ont un
petit défraiement c'est normal et pour
pas qu'on passe dans le hors la loi il
ya il ya il ya aussi des recommandations
à faire les frais de déplacement et moi
je dis c'est très important
c'est là que qu'on voit si un club est
bien structuré et l'utilité de l'argent
public parce que plus de 80% voire 90%
c'est quand même de l'argent public et
l'argent public on n'a pas le droit de
faire ce qu'on veut avec est aussi vient
s'ajouter les cotisations des enfants
des parents ils mettent leurs enfants et
paient une cotisation il faut que cet
argent aussi soient bien utilisés donc
moi pour moi le contrôle est nécessaire
alors il ya un cas qui posent
particulièrement problème dans les
yvelines cette année c'est le cas du fc
mantois qui vient d'être rétrogradé en
nationale 3 par soucis financiers de
160000 euros due notamment à la
suppression de la subvention de la
mairie de mantes la ville
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce cas
principalement qui marche bien vengé au
fait qu elle je fais partie j'ai fait
partie de la commission qui a pendant
ces sept mesures à l'égard du fc mantois
mais vous savez quand on prend cette
mode et en même temps on dit au club
m'ont probablement
vous serez appel de ces décisions on
pourrait presque dire donc ouvrage en
est on va écouter remédier à cela sont
présentes au jour d'aujourd'hui aller
devant la commission d'appel rectifier
vos comptes présentés fatalement des
ressources additionnelles et puis ma je
pense que je devrais commission appelle
ça devrait s'arranger
ils ont fait appel il ya également le
cas de fernand mendy qui a été transféré
de lyon au real madrid pour 50 millions
d'euros et le club devrait récupérer en
tant que club formateur à 0 5% de la
somme ce qui ferait de 240000 euros
est ce que ça peut les sauver alors ça
c'est une très bonne chose ça c'est pas
toujours connus ou suivis par les clubs
du niveau national 2
c'est qu'effectivement les clubs
devraient suivre l'évolution de la
carrière de leur ancien joueur pour
toucher cette fameuse indemnité de
préformation ou en formation dans le cas
du fc mantois b coups de cisailles à
toucher à percevoir cette somme avant la
date fixée et parce que normalement
c'est le 30 juin à la date de fin
d'exercice thème 30 juin bien j'imagine
que tout devrait rentrer dans l'ordre
mais je ne peux pas de me substituer la
commission d'appel de la dncg qui va
statuer sur ce cas
cette fin une bonne fois pour de récup
et à cette femme c'est même
indispensable
alors avant de refermer cette page
football un bon mercato à présent après
à laurent fournier au poste d'entraîneur
lespes aussi réalisé un nouveau gros
coup nous mounir obbadi 36 ans ancien
joueur de monaco et de nice arrive de
laval pour s'engager avec le club de
nationale 2 le milieu ex international
marocain a paraphé un contrat fédéral de
deux années c'est un retour aux sources
pour celui qui a débuté à
chanteloup-les-vignes fois ci devrait
également recruté cette semaine le
latéral droit mathieu rangoly 30 ans
formé au paris saint germain il a
disputé 11 rencontres nationales de
l'année dernière avec les lusitanos
saint maur
c'est une bonne recrue pour poissy ou
qui avait joué uniquement je ne connais
pas ses joueurs pour nous parler d'avoir
ont vu je veux bien l'avouer mais
j'imagine que le site a été recrutée je
note quand même ce sont des joueurs qui
ont du métier qui ont une expérience
d'un certain âge donc à certains post
crise a peut être quelque chose
d'intéressant pour le club que d'assurer
la bonne tenue de ses potes donc non à
jouer leur arrivée
je l'aurais faire le leur souhaite le
meilleur succès possible au sein du club
merci à tous et de dettes passées sur ce
plateau on vous souhaite de bonnes
vacances on se reverra à la rentrée pour
une nouvelle saison
hameau de cyclisme sur piste à présent
les jeux européens se dérouler la
semaine dernière à minsk en biélorussie
chez les garçons ligne et monte à ryan
et l'alevin emporté la médaille d'argent
en keirin
il a pris la deuxième place derrière le
hollandais a ri à la vraie scène le
sportif avait également remporté une
médaille d'argent avec l'équipe de
france de vitesse chez les filles après
sa déception en keirin mathilde de gros
20 ans remporté la médaille d'argent en
vitesse individuelle
le sportif a été battue en finale par la
russe vol nova les français ont donc
remporté trois médailles de ces jeux
européens
si vous n'avez pas envie de faire du
sport par scea fortes chaleurs pourquoi
ne pas lire du sport sidy diallo
il est monté en plus de 100 marathon
ultramarathon sur sept continents vient
de sortir un livre son nom running human
l'ouvragé explique sur une centaine de
pages les capacités naturelles des
humains à courir pieds nus et sans peine
des dizaine de marathons par an nous
avons pu rencontrer sylvie diallo nous
lui avons posée à trois questions
[Musique]
je veux un 2008 quelque 40000 personnes
qui courait le marathon le marathon de
chicago se passait devant chez moi il se
passer des vessies mois et l'année
suivante en 2009 pareil hein 2010 je
suis décidé de faire comme eux
[Musique]
kenny lala c'est une démarche un peu
différente parce que je me suis rendu
compte qu'en fait des humains nous
sommes des couleurs pour 2010
c'est-à-dire sa chaussure ne sont pas
neuves les chaussures et par 1 3 million
d'années des ancêtres ont chassé il ce
marché ils ont migré pieds nus hier les
européens vous descendez pas vos goûts
vos assiettes sont arrivés pieds nus au
sud de l'europe
j'imagine qu'ils s'étaient l'été parce
que si c'était l'idée de la fédé meet
you
[Musique]
pour moi courir des marathons pieds nus
donc le sait c'est une activité normale
que nos ancêtres exercées pour attraper
les animaux pour manger et que nous on
doit faire pour préserver notre santé
physique et mentale d'un coup un
objectif c'est de continuer d'exercer
cette activité naturelle deuxièmement
que jusqu'à la fin de ma vie donc je
continue à courir des marathons en
france
dans le reste du monde pieds nus juste
pour montrer l'exemple aussi pour
essayer de faire en sorte que les gens
comprennent que comme moi c'est
l'activité normale d'ailleurs j'avais
tout le monde à me suivre c'est que 6 et
que c'est mon tee shirts courir pieds
nus région la tendance
une page insolite à présent une équipe
versaillaise baptisé à titanic qui a
participé au à red bull joue en vol le
week-end dernier à lyon les compétitions
délurée où les participants doivent
propulser leur ovni du haut d'une plate
forme de six mètres après une petite
chorégraphie les jack et rose d'un jour
ont ensuite été notés par un jury
regardez cet extrait de leur compétition
[Musique]
à
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'équipe titanic a terminé 14 elle sur
32 équipes on passe maintenant notre
page agenda de la boxe dans cet agenda
l'illinois tony yoka va remonter sur les
rings après sa suspension d'un an le 13
juillet prochain à l'azur arena
d'antibes le boxeur de 27 ans
originaires de chanteloup les vignes va
affronter le russe alexander dimitrenko
un adversaire classé 35e mondial âgé de
36 ans et compte qui compte quarante et
une victoire pour cinq défaites
tony yoka compte quant à lui cinq
combats professionnels pour cinq
victoires pour préparer ce combat
le français est reparti aux états unis à
las vegas il s'entraîne en ce moment
avec joseph parker le poids lourds néo
zélandais et on termine par du bsb les
cougars de montigny le bretonneux se
déplaceront ce week-end sur le terrain à
des barracuda de montpellier pour le
compte de la deuxième journée des
playoffs de première division match
vital pour les il monte un qui n'auront
pas le droit à l'erreur ils sont pour
l'instant 5e sur six avec le même nombre
de points que leurs adversaires
deux victoires et il pourrait se
relancer en vue d'une finale le match
est programmé à 11 heures ce dimanche
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]